[Music]
let's go to annie in austin texas let's
just go right there what's up annie how
are we doing
good morning i'm doing good how are you
doing very much
doing good too thank you for calling so
what's up in your part of the world
yeah so well i was introduced to you by
my adult daughter who followed you she's
been a d ramsay
follower for a while and
got her finances and all straightened up
to him and i think she came to know you
through that and introduced me but
anyway getting down to the point hey
you've got a wise brilliant daughter you
raised her well way to go
thank you
so what's up
with help from people like y'all
but uh yeah i have a 17 year old son a
high school senior
has been doing well up until summer
break
was actually a top 10
student but then during the summer
he met a girl online from out of town
young girl and
could not get distracted any bad that he
is
and we he told us after
three four months of talking to her and
then i could just see him
constantly we take away his phone for
night but during the days
i mean that he can't get away from his
phone
just completely take nowhere with this
girl
and
it was very hard he doesn't understand
he thinks that you can't
really you guys can't really understand
how it feels what it means
and to a point like she's talking to him
about you know getting married and
having kids
and he's like
it's been hard we talked to him just
stay focused on school and graduate and
get yourself a q a and become 21.
at that moment it seems like he gets it
but then pretty soon you know i think
being in touch with her we took a big
phone
set some limits
but
so it's been going on for a couple of
months now
his dad isn't very
actively involved in his life he's a
good guy but he isn't the kind of guy
that for a teenager
and i feel sometimes so helpless but
yeah so does that does death a couple
questions so does dad live at home
yes okay so you all still together
we
live separate lives but you're under the
same move um okay i mean like reading
around the household but
um
yeah but um so so
let me excuse and how old is this young
lady
oh she's 16.
and
so whoa
yeah she's 16.
until when i how do you know that she's
16
well she told me and my son told me and
i mean how do you know she's 16.
well
she is a sophomore in high school and my
son told me she's 16 and i had a chance
to talk to her
she didn't answer my phone and said that
i said look
you know we have different plans for
ethan and this must stop and you should
call
if not
me and my husband planning to come over
and confront your parents because she's
sending new pictures not news but
you know her breasts and things like
that i've seen i haven't seen any from
my son and
at least he's very open and honest with
us which has been helpful he said like
he never asked her but she's been
sending
and i followed the thread and she's the
one uh you know meeting these kind of
discussions so so here here's a couple
things number one um
your
there's an old there's an old proverb
that says the best time to plant a tree
was 10 years ago
yeah and this type of conversation was
best had 10 years ago but the the next
part of that proverb if i remember
correctly
is the second best time to plant a tree
is today
yeah so here's a couple things number
one your husband does not get to step
out of this conversation anymore
and it's not a flex and it's not a beat
down and it's not a this is my hou not
like that
he needs to sit down and talk to his son
about the first time he fell in love and
maybe the second and third time he he
needs to have some sort of conversation
with his son because his son feels like
he's on an island and he's got some
woman some young kid actually not a
woman some child
sending him nude pictures telling her
him that he is the most special thing in
his world
right and if he's growing up in a
romance-free home
of two parents who are roommates
and
um
he that type of
love that type of attraction that type
of hey you have value and let me show
you how valuable you are
they're already gonna be there because
she's 17.
but and you talk about gasoline on a
fire
and here's the thing
that girl may be 12
she may be 14.
she may be she's a child any time a
child sends any sort of nude picture
then you stop the and you know
you call parents you get them involved
and this isn't even a religious thing
this is a any human ever
i mean she is pretty i was surprised for
her
uh the way she spoke to me over the
phone like she sounded older than me she
said like yeah but my daughter
my daughter told me she was over me and
she was done dealing with me and she's
five so i don't care those kind of words
i don't care about that
um i don't care what she sounds like
more importantly is your son is in
desperate need of adults in his life and
he doesn't have them
he's got an absentee buddy in dad
and he's got a
you're kind of acting like a 17 year old
almost like a sister like hey we're
going to come over there and confront
you like like west side story y'all
going to start snapping and walk across
the middle the street together and the
music's going to play like
he needs adults
and yeah one is the relationship part
where dad says hey man this is what it's
like falling in love you should have
been having those conversations a decade
ago clearly dad didn't so here we are
today
here's what this looks like here's what
heartbreak feels like here's what making
good choices feels like
um
and then there's the
legal ethical
if your child is putting nude photos of
himself out into the world don't want to
break anybody's heart but he's not the
only one
and
some adult in the world has to call the
flag or throw a flag on that one and get
with the other adults in the world right
yeah
and you guys have set boundaries and all
that my fear is this young lady is 14.
yeah and now your son's a felon
well we didn't warn him about that i
don't care yeah but he's 17 year old guy
and they
and a young woman is a young lady is
sending him pictures
you can't that's not a conversation with
a 17 year old like well you know you
need to make good choices no
every part of their brain has been taken
over that's where they need adults in
their life to step in and say i'm
stopping this
yeah you know what i mean
right
um
well you know what helped i mean like
it's been ongoing for a couple of days a
couple months
finally last week
or a christian so
we my husband at least this was a good
aspect he said we're going to fast and
pray we're going to look at the word of
the lord we talked about the story of
samson and about the prodigal son and
the choices that they made
and
so he really that really hit him the
story of particles and he said well i
was at the point of wanting to go
leave you guys and go because that's how
attractive but so to to use that story i
think you're missing the point of that
story
okay the point of the prodigal son is
not that the boy went home ran away and
acted like an idiot
the point of that story is dad never
gave up
and dad never stopped loving him and dad
went to the ends of the earth to go get
him
dad met him at the front of that road
yeah and what your son needs isn't a
bible story or a lecture he needs debt i
mean all those things are fine and good
he needs a dad to sit with him and say
this is what love is this is what a
felony is this is what destroying your
life and some other young child's life
is he needs a mom and a dad to get in a
car together and drive over and meet
with his parents
yeah he needs that
i think we need to do something more
aggressive like you said
and it
it doesn't have to be aggressive
it has to be intentional
right
i'm not talking about setting things on
fire i'm not talking about starting
fights i'm talking about saying i will
go to the ends of the earth to love you
i will conti and you're a child
you're not allowed to buy cigarettes
you're not allowed to go to war you're
not allowed to buy guns not buy beer
you're a child
and you're in a relationship that is now
turned into a pornographic relationship
with another child
and we're getting in the middle of it
yeah you hear what i'm saying
you know what he said once he said mom i
have this boy in my classmate he has a
daughter and he seems happy
i was like you don't know what's going
on behind the doors he may be
uh you know
showing to be happy that may not be the
case behind the doors in their house you
never know what's going on in his life
but that's never he's a child and he has
a child how would that work right
your son
hear this your son is screaming out for
a connection
with anybody i'm not ever gonna fault
the 17 year old for getting infatuated
with
some girl or some boy i'm never gonna
get upset with that that's the way
they're wired
i'll only get frustrated with parents
who don't step in and protect their
children from themselves because that's
what parents do they do boundaries they
do directness
they get involved
get involved annie get involved today
contact the other kids parents and
anybody out there listening if your
kid's getting nude photos from another
child you gotta turn the lights on that
deal
you got it
i'm just telling you man i've been too
many meetings with too many people too
many investigations with too many it
just gets messy
i'm telling you get involved with that
nonsense ah they're just kids nope
cause when it's on the internets it's
forever
when it's on your phone it's forever
get involved you gotta get involved
danny